- Ryan, why don't you introduce yourself?
Let's go right into the
origin story, I think,
obviously, given that this
is the real estate track.
By show of hands, how
many people know who this
extremely handsome man is?
(audience cheering)
Okay so, obviously, I
think a lot of people
know who you are, but is there
anything that you wanna cover
or stuff that hasn't
been covered by the show
or in the mainstream media from a nuance,
something that you think brings value?
Obviously, you got to
hear the opening keynote,
so maybe there's some build on that.
As just setting this up before we go into
a little bit of a chat here.
Is there anything you
think they should know?
- Sure, I am the original anti-salesmen.
Like, by far.
I never wanted to be a real
estate broker in my entire life.
I think if you had told
me when I was 10 years old
that I was gonna grow up
to be a real estate broker,
let alone a real estate broker on TV,
I would have said that
you're fucking crazy.
(audience laughing)
One, because I never
wanted a real job, right?
That was the one thing I ran
away from as hard as possible.
And two, like, real estate, really?
Especially when I was a little kid.
I saw the real estate agents
that my parent worked with,
and I was like, I don't wanna
do that, I wanna be awesome.
I don't wanna be a
broker, that's terrible.
And then I grew up,
and I went to New York
City to try to be an actor,
and that was way harder than
Brad Pitt makes it seem.
(audience laughing)
And that was a wake-up call.
And I grew up outside Boston
and then went to college.
Yeah, and then I went to
college in upstate New York.
(audience laughing)
- Just realized there's a
lot more Patriot fans here
than I wanted.
- Wait, could I break
from the origin story
for one second to tell a funny story?
- Great.
- So I meet Gary for the first time,
well, I met him before,
but we actually had
breakfast on Monday morning,
and we sit there, and we sit down,
and one of the first
things he says to me is,
you know what, I'm gonna
talk about the Patriots,
because the Patriots had just
won the AFC Championship,
right, on Sunday, so there's nothing--
- Ryan, this was three days ago.
Everybody's following along, keep going.
(audience cheering)
- And he's such a
die-hard awesome Jets fan,
which I think is great,
right, to have love
and everything for his sport that way.
And he said, there's nothing I hate more
than a 33-year-old Patriots fan.
(audience laughing)
So, I'm 33.
(laughing)
And I grew up outside Boston.
And I'm a proud Patriots fan,
and it's okay, all right?
- You know what's interesting?
Actually just to build
on something earlier.
My theory on 33, I can't believe that.
I did say that, I said, I was
talking about the Patriots
and I was talking about, if you're 33
and you've been a Patriot
fan or you're a Boston fan,
you suck, similar to the point
that I was making out there
about if you weren't
punched in the mouth yet,
because you've been in
business since 2009,
if you're 33 and a Boston sports fan,
you've won all four championships,
you win all the time,
and so in a weird way,
I think that slightly makes you a loser.
(audience laughing and applauding)
I do, I do.
- Yes.
- So anyway, go ahead, Ryan.
- So that happened on Monday.
- Tell these two ladies who you are,
'cause they were whispering
to each other, who is that?
- Right, for people who
don't know who I am.
Is this on, right, you can hear?
- Yeah, you're on.
- My name is Ryan Serhant
and I do a TV show on Bravo called,
Million Dollar Listing New York
and I've been on since the beginning.
We started taping that show in 2010,
it didn't come out 'til 2012,
and right now we're taping Season 7,
and I actually have my
own show on Bravo now
called Sell it Like Serhant
that will premiere this spring
I'm not allowed to tell you
when yet because it's a big date
and it'll come out this
spring and it's just me.
So you better watch it,
all these people in here.
It's the first kind of business show
that Bravo has done like this
and so it's gonna be pretty cool.
- Set up your fucking DVR.
Do we still have those,
do they still exist?
No, right, like it's
un-fuckin'-believable.
These technologies come in and out.
All right, so Ryan--
- Yeah.
- You didn't want to do that, but you did,
you know, you were
telling your origin story,
you said a real estate
broker, but one on TV,
that caught my attention
because you did come,
you did want to be a TV,
you wanted to be an actor.
- Yeah, I--
- When did that happen?
- When I was like four, I think.
I made my little brother do
little home movies with me.
My mom was the videographer and I made,
I had this whole trove of
home movies that I made
where I kill my little
brother, I don't know why.
Every single movie, he
just happens to die.
- Is his name Kenny?
- Yeah, my little brother's name is Jack.
And no matter what, though,
I knew that I wanted to
grow up and be successful.
No matter what I did, I
thought it was gonna be acting,
I thought I was gonna
be on Broadway, right,
that was my thing, and it
didn't work out for me.
And I thought that that was devastating.
I did a soap opera for a
little short period of time
when I first came to New York
and then they killed me off, karma, right?
And they killed me off--
- What show, what show?
- As The World Turns.
I took a, Evan Walsh IV, that's who I was,
and I took a syringe to the heart
while I was on top of a hospital
awaiting my helicopter to
take me to the Caribbean
where I could do my research in peace.
And then I thought my life was over.
And I had no money and
I lived in Koreatown
and it was, go home to Colorado
where my parents then moved to
and paint fence for the
rest of my life, or it was--
- Hold on, hold on, oh, your
parents lived in Colorado?
- Yeah.
- How long?
- They moved to Colorado
when I graduated high school
in 2002.
- I was gonna make a point
about the Patriots thing,
but keep going.
(audience laughing)
- So, I didn't want to go home and I said,
you know what, I'll stay in New
York, I gotta make this work
because from when I was a little
kid, I chose success first.
Whatever I was gonna do to be successful,
I would figure out later.
And I mean a lot of people who say,
I want to be a successful
real estate agent,
but they choose real estate first,
so they choose something else first.
And I think that's where a lot of people
that make the mistake because if they have
a small little hiccup or a
small little bump in the road,
it's like world over for them.
Oh, I lost that deal, world over.
What am I gonna do, oh, my life is over.
But if you choose success
first, that's what I did.
So I had no money, I lived in Koreatown,
I didn't want to go home,
and so I got my real estate license.
It was like 300 bucks at the
time and I rented apartments
for 1,000, 2,000 bucks a
month on 31st and 32nd Street.
And I did shares, I found three people,
put them in a one-bedroom,
put up fake walls,
I ran all over the place.
I didn't have a suit,
and that's what I did.
And then there was an open
casting call in the Real Deal
curbed for a show called
Million Dollar Listing New York,
which is gonna be the New
York franchise of the LA show,
and I went to an open casting call
at the Hudson Hotel with 3,000 agents.
And they took everyone
30 seconds at a time,
with 3,000 of us, and they said,
why should you be on the show?
And I said, why the fuck do you think
I should be on this show?
- You showed 'em your face?
- No, I just said, all I
said was, I'm the greatest.
And they bought it.
(audience laughing)
And then I had to figure it out
after six months of casting and they said,
okay, we're gonna put you on the show
and there were four of us.
- Ryan, on a serious note,
the greatest, definitely
came out of your mouth
but were you able to say,
like on a very, very tangible
note, were you able to say,
hey look, I was on the
fucking As The World Turns,
obviously, I'm in the game.
Did that like, on a very serious kick?
- Not really, because they
were really pushing to find
the best real estate
agents in New York City.
- Which you weren't.
- No, they started casting
at the beginning 2010.
My first day in real
estate brokerage at all
with September 15, 2008.
That was the day Lehman
Brothers filed for bankruptcy,
which is the only reason I know that date.
Because that was my first
day in the conference room.
Like, dude, I'm gonna be a broker now.
It's gonna be awesome.
And everyone's staring at the TV
as the world comes crashing down
and for a lot of people,
right, it was awful.
For me, I had no money.
- For everybody to,
because I think I'm gonna
bounce a little bit from the talk earlier.
It's interesting, I almost feel weird
because I feel like we're
about to predict like a crash,
like we keep referencing
this day back in 2008.
Just for, again, for people
that are early in their career
or were in different businesses.
On that day, within 24
hours, Wine Library,
when you sell wine, you can pre-sell it
and you can sell futures,
so we get to take the money
and the customer gets to
save a lot of money on a wine
that comes out 18 months
later, and you can only do that
with the most sought-after wine, right?
No different than the most sought-after
anything that you do, right?
Literally, within 24 hours of that day,
we had 1.7 million dollars
of 2.4 million dollars
of Bordeaux that was sold
have to be refunded because
that many people knew
the world had just crashed or
worked at a Wall Street firm.
Literally, that's how
much it melted, literally.
And don't forget, we're
playing on that float
so we're using those
dollars for other things
'cause it's in, and you
know up until that point,
for nine years, we had 1% cancellations.
So it was a significant, I
mean, like you're not joking.
If you walked in like, you
know, wide-eyed and excited,
like literally the veterans
in that office were like,
fuck, we're about to go through
a three to five year
window of straight shit.
- Yeah, and so, hindsight's 20/20.
So it was the worst time
to get started in business,
but at the same time, it
was the absolute best time
because a lot of brokers were
getting out of the business,
right, the guy who got
me into the business,
a friend of mine from college,
he was selling apartments on Craigslist,
that's all he needed to do.
Put ads on Craigslist,
would meet people on the street corner,
take them a few buildings
in New York City.
They'd buy one, contracts
were signed on the spot,
10% deposit stated income
loans all day, that was it.
The day I started, all
of that disappeared.
So with the reason I
got into the business--
- Hey, bro, it's just Craigslist.
we're gonna fucking kill it.
- And people were starting
up brokerages everywhere,
right, when times are great
everyone can do anything.
And so I said, okay, I'll
do this to pay my rent,
pay for food, and that
way I can go to auditions
and do things, you know,
that I want to do on my own.
And then the minute I did my
first deal and I made $1,000
because I rented a
$2,000-a-month apartment
and commissions, you know,
in New York City anyway,
are one month's rent,
let's say, on a rental,
and a brand new broker, you
take 50-50 with the house.
And that was a one day showing,
I got $1,000 and I was rich.
And I remember that day, it
was models and bottles all day.
(audience laughing)
- So you flew back to Boston
because you definitely
couldn't have afforded that in New York,
which is a first-rate City.
- Well, exactly, my rent where I was,
was $1167 at the time,
so that was towards rent.
And then I just wanted to make sure
that I did as many deals as possible.
Then all of a sudden I
was like, wait a minute,
there's only so much time in the day.
Why am i spending so much time
going to Actors Equity
auditions and sitting here
and being told no to my face
and no about my gray hair
and no about this and no
about that, it's so personal,
when I can meet people on the street,
I could show them
apartments that aren't mine,
I don't have to do anything else
other than make personal connections,
and then if they like a
space, I get paid for it.
Like, I didn't create anything,
especially when I was a brand new agent.
I was like, this is a job?
And anybody can do it.
You can get off a boat in
New York City with under $500
and that is it,
you can make millions
and millions of dollars
and all you have to do
is meet human beings?
And that was my ah ha moment, right?
And there was a guy in my office--
- If you have the
serendipity of your parents
having sex at the exact moment
that gave you the charisma
and people skills to be
able to do that, right?
I mean, I think the thing
that's super-interesting for me
from afar about this industry is that--
- I'll respond.
(audience laughing)
- The game is extremely lucrative
for a certain personality trait.
To me, what's so attractive
about this industry is,
it is the greatest ROI, if you
have a certain human skill,
because there's a ton of people
who can never sell anything
because their personal skills suck, right?
Like, the emotional intelligence,
which is emerging in society, period,
has always been a huge
arbitrage in real estate.
No, I'm asking?
- I disagree.
- Go ahead.
- When I first got into real estate,
that was my one deal, I got addicted.
And then like most people
who get into real estate,
I did no deals and then
I couldn't figure it out.
I was like, this sucks, this sucks.
But there was a guy in my office,
his name was Ben, and he
was from Bed-Stuy Brooklyn,
get his first kit when he was 17.
- Ben from Bed-Stuy.
- Yeah.
- Okay, keep going.
- Right, gets his first kit
when he was 17, he sold drugs,
and he got into real estate
to help pay the bills.
And he did deals every single day.
- 'Cause he was a drug dealer.
That's the best fucking
training in the game.
- Maybe, maybe.
(audience laughing and applauding)
- I only want a higher drug, but--
- He was completely quiet, you should.
- Guys drug-dealing, listen,
I make a lot of content
for 15 to 17 year-olds on
Instagram and I hit up,
I talk to them on DM all the time
and these kids are fucking
selling a lot of weed
and I'm like dick-face, do you understand
that you all you have to do
is just take that same skill
and make that about Yeezys and Supremes
and you'll make 10X the
money and you'll be legit.
I mean, drug dealing
is the training ground
for gangsters and sales.
(audience laughing and applauding)
Because not only do you have to sell,
you have to fucking navigate the law.
And your parents...
I'm a big fan of drug dealers.
- No one who works for me
sells drugs, by the way.
But I don't think it's just charisma.
I think anybody can sell,
anybody can be taught to sell.
Obviously, there are people
with natural-born talent,
who have charisma, who
have great personalities
and they're people-people.
But then there are other people
that don't like that like.
That's why I started this
conversation by saying
that I was the anti-salesman.
Dude, I was overweight, chubby,
face riddled with acne
when I was in high school.
I didn't want to talk to anybody,
my Saturday nights were snick, right?
There's guys in here that
I went to high school with.
I didn't have that many friends,
I didn't want to talk
to anybody, I was shy,
totally ruined my self-confidence.
The last thing I ever wanted to do
was go into Starbucks in Manhattan
and try to talk to people
about renting apartments.
Are you kidding me, I don't
know what talking about.
But my back was up against the wall
because I had no money
so I had to figure out,
okay, if I'm gonna stay here,
I've got my real estate license,
I might as well figure out how to do this.
I'm gonna leave my self-consciousness
and my ego at the door,
whatever that might be,
and I'm just gonna start
hawking real estate.
I'm gonna talk about it like
I know what I'm talking about.
I'm just gonna figure it out.
And then I worked every single day.
And that's what the new
show on Bravo is about.
It's called Sell it Like Serhant
and it's working with people
who are the worst salespeople
in the history of the world.
And you will see, it is ridiculous.
And helping them through
what their hurdles are,
figuring out what their wall is,
figuring out what their
what is, what their who is,
what their win is, right?
But your win is just
to make a lot of money,
it's gonna be hard for you,
is how do you work towards that every day?
I'm gonna make a lot of
money today, okay, great.
Okay go do it.
But if you figure out what your
win is and what your wall is
like, what's the worst thing
that could happen to you
if you don't sell something today?
That's your motivation for
tomorrow, and I think that
anybody who doesn't
have a great personality
or great charisma right now
can become a great salesperson,
if they work at it.
But everybody has different
hurdles they gotta get over.
- So let's talk about this,
to make it about the audience.
Obviously, as your profile grew
with the success of the show,
what is the majority of
questions you're being asked
via DMs on Instagram, via email,
when somebody stops you in the street,
what is the current state of questions
in the sector that are coming to you
based on where you're
positioned in the market?
- Everybody asks how to get started.
I mean, everybody asks
me, how do I get started,
or they've been in the
business for a year or two,
and they don't know how to get started.
That's what everybody wants to know.
Even downstairs, we were
on the field with you
and people asking, what do I do?
Like, how do I get over
that kind of like first hump
in the business, I don't know anybody,
I don't have connections, I don't have,
I don't even know, you
know, with the paperwork,
what do I do, and I tell everybody,
there's two things you need to do.
No matter what, you meet five
new people every single day
because you have to add
to your social currency.
We talked about that, right?
You got to add to your data book, right?
Your Rolodex, your Excel
sheet, whatever you use.
And you have to work with somebody else.
You cannot do it by yourself.
That was the biggest mistake that I made,
that a lot of people think
they can get into real estate,
they got their license,
boom I'm gonna be the best broker ever.
Work with someone who's been
in the business forever,
work for them for free, just
listen to the conversation,
listen to how they talk to people.
Look at how they write their emails,
meet the brokers that they know,
meet the clients that they
know, learn from them.
Take the best, leave the
rest, and do it on your own.
That's what I tell people.
That's it.
(audience applauding)
- It's interesting to
me, obviously, you know,
you've gotten passionate
about teaching sales,
you're reverse-engineering yourself,
because it didn't come naturally.
You just told your high
school story, which was fun.
Do you think it's better for people to,
you know, so I think you think about sales
the way I think about any
skill and I agree with you,
which is, everybody here
can be better at everything.
You could be a better singer
than you are right now.
My biggest question always is,
you could be better at basketball,
you could be better at
playing American football,
but I have a good feeling
that you weren't built
to be on the field here every Sunday.
I'm very fascinated by the Mendoza line
of somebody trying to
become a salesperson,
get better at sales,
what's their upside,
because I agree with you,
they can go from here to here,
but does it close the delta
that they should do that
versus spending a lot of time
trying a lot of different
things and becoming self-aware
and figuring out the thing
that has their biggest upside?
When you think about this,
and as you're going through
probably a process that
happened similar to me,
it was my first decade in business,
it was about me
establishing what I wanted,
then you start reverse, you
start asking yourselves like,
how the fuck did this happen,
why is this happening?
Start thinking about
how you were parented,
where you come from, a lot of, you know,
I talk about a lot of this stuff.
I was just curious for myself
and I thought it'd be interesting here,
do you think that sales is such
an incredibly core skill set
that everybody should
try to get better at that
or do you think that some people
just have this little upside with that
and the real game is self-awareness
and trying to figure themselves out
because maybe they're an operator,
maybe they're a back-office person,
maybe owning 3% of a company,
where somebody else is
doing all that magic
because they're just
organized and meticulous
and they've got huge upside and that,
they'll never drop any ball
but really their sales will only go up.
So where do you put sales
as a skill and it's upside
versus self-awareness?
- For one, I think that
everybody's a salesperson,
whether you think you are or not, right?
I mean, when I was a little
kid, like I said, right,
I had a little bit of a weight problem.
I was selling my mom on
giving me more pudding.
Like, I really liked
those Jello Snack Packs
with whipped cream on top and
I liked to have three of them.
I don't know why that was a problem.
And so my mom, my parents,
didn't want me to eat that much.
And I had to negotiate with them,
I had to sell them on why
I should have an extra one.
I balanced out time,
instead of having them all
right at four o'clock,
said, you know what,
I do one four, one at seven,
and then if I do this one thing for you,
I'll get one before I go to bed.
And that's where I really
learned how to sell.
All of us sell something,
even if you're back office,
even if you're IT, you
are selling a program,
you are selling your system
of how to manage email,
you're selling the fact that
you need to come in at 5:00
because that's better for your schedule
than coming in at 9:00
when it's better for
your client's schedule.
So we're all salespeople
and we can all become better salespeople,
which will help us do better
at whatever it is our job is.
But I agree with you in a little bit
that I don't think everybody
should be a real estate agent.
I don't feel that everybody should be
selling body lotion on the street, right?
I worked with someone on
the show who did that.
That's the only reason I mentioned that.
But I think that you have
to find what you love
and that you can actually
make money doing, right?
I kind of hate it when
people say, do what you love
and you'll never work a day in your life.
That's great, if you fucking have money.
- Do you think that, right?
So honestly, I'm very fascinated
by this subject matter.
I know I live a very interesting life.
I was such a terrible student
that a lot of my high school
and specifically my college friends,
and even less so my college friends,
my college acquaintances,
I mean, a stunning percentage
of the people that I knew
between six and 22 make
under $75,000 a year.
And a stunning percentage of the people
that I've been doing
business with from 2007
to 2012
make over or have net worth
over five million dollars a year.
And I'm kind of like, I
live almost in this Bizarro,
two different world world.
And I am fascinated by
how many of my friends
that make $67,000 a year
and have hit their zone are
truly truly truly happy.
- That's right.
- And how many are at 17
million dollars net worth
and are miserable as fuck.
You know, to me, I
genuinely do believe that
rich is a very funny kind of vague,
self kind of inside game.
So for example, this is just my truth.
When I made $100,000
a year, that was like,
I've never felt the same way since.
I've never felt as at peace.
That was a number for me like,
I was comfortable living my
lifestyle under that monarchy.
I'm fascinated by this conversation.
I really think a lot more,
this is why I talk a lot about
doing, like going very niche.
So for me, I'm a big believer
that a lot of people here
who make 236 a year should make 147
putting out content around
Alf the sitcom from the 80s.
What I'm fascinated by
is the extreme long tail of the internet
and the monetization of crazy niches.
How many people here are
familiar with the fact
that eight to 10 year-old,
six to 10 year-old girls
in America are making slime
at home like in a big way?
So good, do you know
about this phenomenon?
- No.
- Okay, so homemade
slime, right, it's huge.
I know a couple people
who were in love with arts and crafts,
loved making this stuff
and have been doing this,
and making little videos about
slime making for six years.
Literally, that was their
lives and then you know,
the market comes to them.
They were making $13,000 a year
in Adsense three years ago.
Now they're making a million
to two million dollars a year
in branded content and ads
and things of that nature and higher.
I think this is the beginning.
I'm fascinated by the,
do you think the wealth thing
and I think you're right,
and let me tell you where on the subtlety,
rich or what-have-you,
I think it's a lot
easier when your income,
how much you take home, is
controlled by what you spend.
People get stressed
when their balance sheet
and P&L is broken.
So some people know how
to live under 100,000
and there's people in here
making half a million,
but they're buying so much shit
that they're so vulnerable,
and deep down, deep down they are stressed
because they know if shit
hits the fan, they're fucked.
Where do you actually sit
on this happiness of work
dollar kind of conversation?
Like, nuanced, I heard
you, but next level?
- I live and I tell people to live
probably 10% over comfortable, right?
Whatever your comfort level is,
don't go 100% over because
we've all read in the news,
you've seen the articles, you've
seen somebody on the street
who went 100% over comfortable
and that was stupid, right?
So I never tell people to
live outside their means
or to live at their means, either.
Because then how are
you gonna push yourself?
The only way that I got over
$100,000 a year was by saying,
this is great, I'm not broke,
but it's still not enough, right?
- Are you are you at enough now?
- No.
- Do you think you'll ever be at enough?
No.
- That means you love the process.
That means it's not the money.
- Yeah.
- What's that?
Sure, trust it, but like, he loves it.
Trusting it is different
than loving it, right?
I don't trust that if I
work hard, it'll be okay.
I love working hard.
- Yeah.
- I love fucking being the working dog--
- And I love working for myself.
- Because, well, he just loves
he just loves the process.
- What's up, Ruben?
- So you think you love the process.
- I love the work, right?
- Right.
- I love the process and I love,
I love doing whatever I
want to do every single day
and not having to punch in or punch out.
I just didn't want to do it.
I was like, I'm gonna live a short life
and then I will die, and that will be it.
And the worst thing in the
world for me is to say,
good thing I went to my job.
Like, that sucks, and that
terrified me when I was 10.
I remember like crying in the bathtub.
I was a weird little kid, but
I was crying in the bathtub
about growing up doing
nothing and then dying.
And so I said to myself--
- Do you have any clue why that happened?
Was there like a grandparent, a parent?
Did you watch some weird soap opera?
Do you have any clue
why that was happening?
- I think a lot of it came
from my parents, for sure.
A lot of it came from my parents.
I was raised very, very strict,
and they always had me
work incredibly hard
to understand the value of
the dollar, the value of work,
and the value of making
something of yourself
because no one else is going to do it.
And that's what was hard
for me about acting,
that I could do the best
audition ever, right--
- But somebody else had control.
- Yeah, someone else had control.
Or someone else looked a different way,
or someone else did that.
- Do you, knowing that you're vlogging now
and building your profile,
do you view the way I'm producing media
as potentially a better way than the way
that you're doing it through television?
Because you have even more control?
- Uh oh.
- Because listening to you carefully,
what must be massively frustrating
is the way they post-edit the show
when you knew that you put magic,
but they're trying to create
a narrative on that episode.
- Sort of, I mean, listen, TV is TV.
Maybe it will eventually change,
but networks have been
pretty good recently
about adapting different forms of media.
And I would not be here
today if it weren't--
- Right, ultimately the
ROI is so extraordinary
in the direction,
you can deal with some
of the shortcomings.
- I mean, of course, and
whatever I put on on TV,
it's not like CGI, it was me doing it.
And if things get cut for
time, they get cut for time.
But listen, Million Dollar Listing airs
to 25 million people around the world.
I can't do that, even on social media.
I mean, not right now.
- Well, you could.
- Yeah, maybe, eventually,
but not when I'm a 33 Patriots fan, right?
- I get it.
- Right?
- So especially when
you're starting, right?
That was a huge layup for me.
Oh, it's the catalyst.
- But I think that
what's great now is that
you don't have to wait for a
3,000-person open casting call.
You could do what we're talking about.
- How many people watch the show?
Okay, great, quite a bit, so
let's get into some of that.
Who is your favorite cast member?
Who are you actually like friendly with,
or like let's get into some of these shit.
- My wife.
- I know that.
- She's right there, by the way.
- I keep looking at her out
of a corner of my right eye.
- Is she the radar?
- Yes, she gives me this--
- Besides your lovely wife,
who is your favorite, and
there's been different people
that have come in and out, honestly,
you know, there's a positive,
this isn't who do you hate,
who of the crew have,
you know, the characters
have you liked the most or
have a relationship with
or maybe you don't,
it's all professional.
- Who of the three of us?
- Well, there's been what,
six of you through the years?
How many have there
been through the years?
- New York, not so many, there
was Michael Lorber, Season 1.
- The dude from the first year, yeah.
- And then there was--
- There's a new dude
who's a model, Luis.
- And there's Steve.
- So that's it, six.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I mean, I've always
had the best camaraderie,
even though we've had some
ups and downs with Fred
because we've been in it
together from the beginning.
He's also 10 years older than I am
and so we were never like contemporaries,
we weren't peers.
- Right.
- I was young and he was doing, you know,
he'd been in the business for 10 years.
I still haven't, to this day,
been in this business for 10 years.
My 10-year anniversary is this September,
and so he had already
been doing real estate.
So I got into it trying to figure out
how the hell am I gonna find listings
to put on a Million Dollar Listing show?
I'm renting apartments in
the financial district.
I told them I was the greatest broker
in the history of the world, holy shit.
I gotta figure this out,
and that's what I did.
It was the best thing
that the show did for me,
was it was a metaphorical
shotgun to my head
to not stop working because
the last thing I needed
was a show to millions of
people telling everyone
that I sucked at real estate.
That would be no good for business,
so I made sure that,
and I always think about
future Ryan, right,
myself five years from now,
because I don't care about
myself yesterday, he's dead.
I care about myself tomorrow,
I care about myself in five years.
So I think every day about future Ryan,
what should I pitch today
that will help future Ryan.
And the same thing with the show, right?
We film a year in advance sometimes.
- I have a good idea for you, real quick.
- Yeah.
- Where's your team,
like your content team?
- They're there, that's Adam,
that's Alice, that's Joe.
- You guys have to get
somebody to draw a future Adam,
a future Ryan, excuse
me, you have to create
a future Ryan cartoon character
and when you reference it
you need to edit it in, cool.
- Do that.
(laughing)
Dude, I'll talk to you, I got
you, it'll be a stick figure.
- I think it's an
interesting thought, right?
I think it's super-important to,
not project like, I'm gonna be successful,
it's just being, it's
about being thoughtful
about the chess moves and
creating your strategy
of where you want to be,
you know, from a happy zone,
from a financial zone,
from a professional zone.
- Yeah.
Because everyone talks
about living in the now.
That's great, but the now is
whoever you prepared to be
for the last five years, right?
So, I know I came to New
York City to be an actor,
but it's a bit serendipitous
that I quit acting,
well, I was fired, but quit,
got out of it, didn't like
it, hated that business.
No one in college teaches
you the business of acting.
They teach you how to
be a clock and a frog
and that's your craft, and
then you go to New York,
and they're like, we don't
want you to be a frog,
we want you to look like
this and dance like this.
No, okay, no money for you.
And that by getting out of it
and getting into real estate,
I then get back in front of a camera
to do what I wanted to do
in the first place anyway
because I set up those building
blocks from the beginning.
So that was my story, those
are my building blocks.
You have to figure out what your own are.
Like what is it, maybe
it's real estate and food.
There are agents I know who
are so obsessed with food,
that's their passion, real
estate to them is a job,
and so they mix them both.
Every week, they have weekly
dinners with their clients.
They cook, they figure out new recipes,
every listing they do,
they take listing photos with food in it
because that's what they
love, that's what gets them up
every single day, that's their thing.
If your thing is cats, cat it up, right?
Want cats everywhere, if
that's what makes you happy
because progress is happiness.
And if you're doing a
little bit more tomorrow
than you were doing today,
that's gonna set you up
for future you.
And if you don't think that
way, then I don't know.
That's my stress, my stress
isn't financial stress.
Even if I buy something,
even if I do something,
I know I'm gonna work my ass off,
everything's gonna be okay,
I don't let that affect me.
What I let affect me is
that I'm not planning
and that I'm not using
enough of my potential
because one day I will be dead, right?
And then you know, you talk
about this a lot, as well,
that one day we will be dead,
and did you milk your potential
as much as you possibly could?
- I think that's why--
- Five people a day.
- I think it's hard to quantify
how ridiculously rare it is
to become a human being, it's
just not what we think about,
and then how quickly
it all happens, right?
Like I mean, it just goes so fast, right?
You know, it's the same
old thing in life, right?
It takes forever, but
it seems like yesterday.
But yeah, to me the bigger issue at hand
is the practical things.
There were humans like us who
lived during the Black Plague.
That was in the world and a
stunning amount of us died.
People that lived during
the great, you know,
the greatest generation.
We talk a lot about in the U.S. were like,
for a lot of people that
were born in the late 1800s,
like you know, early 1900s,
the prime of their lives
were during real conflict in the world,
wars and things of that nature.
We, all of us, everyone
from the oldest person here
to the youngest, have lived
in unbelievable prosperity.
It has been so.
I don't know.
I like looking at history
to, things wrap around data.
It is very impossible
for me to get excited
about complaining about dumb shit,
like the line was too
long, or I got the wrong,
I got skim milk instead of almond milk.
Stuff that I hear people talk about,
when we, us humans, are living through
the greatest era that humans
have ever lived through,
of prosperity and wealth
and happiness and health.
This is ridiculous,
and now on top of that,
you layer this thing called the Internet,
which is a new invention
on the consumer side
and scales the living shit
out of all of our ambitions and wants
and eliminates the middleman
that you hate so much.
Winners hate the middleman because
that's somebody that can stop merit.
What bothered you was merit.
What I am blown away by, by the Internet
and where all your opportunities
sit is the merit of it all.
If you're not doing well,
it's 'cause you suck.
The market is telling you, you suck.
I love how people are like,
how the fuck is that person got
87,000 followers, she sucks.
I'm like, well, you suck
more, because you have 1300,
and you've decided to
make that your judgment.
And not that you should
trade on followers,
but like the day of judging,
you know, back in the day,
Rick the casting guy decided
you weren't cute enough,
smiley enough, funny enough,
so Rick could have been flawed.
We are now living in a platform
that is exposing the truths.
If you're not doing well, it
means you're not good at it.
And so many people are spending time
trying to tear down
other people's buildings
instead of focusing on how to
getting their shit together.
What up.
- Yeah.
- I got an interesting question here
that I've been thinking about.
What happens to future Ryan in five years?
Where are you, like right this second,
you're thinking about him.
I'm dying to hear your
current bullet points on him.
- Someone just asked me that on the field.
They thought, where is everything
gonna be in five years?
And I think more than just me, I think,
I mean, how many people in
here are real estate agents
or real estate brokers?
- All of them, this is
the real estate track.
- Oh thanks.
(audience laughing)
Just wanna make sure.
I do these things, and I ask that,
and like four people raise their hands.
I'm like, oh, I went to the wrong one.
(laughing)
So, I honestly think
within the next five years
the brokerage model as we
know it in the United States
will be over, that is my prediction.
- So let's go, that's
a hyperbole statement.
It's a short period of time.
Give me the nuances underneath that.
I'm naive, I don't even know
what the brokerage model is.
Explain in detail what you mean by that.
- It's extrapolating on what
you're talking about right now.
It's that anybody can market themselves
in any other way they want,
they can cut out the middle person.
Why do I have to go to a brokerage
that takes 20%, 10%, 30%,
50% for me to go and meet
somebody to make money
when I showed them an apartment
or sell them an apartment?
What's the brokerage for?
I understand that there's
a legal need for it now.
But I do think that
that's going to change.
Maybe it's not five years,
maybe it's a little more.
- Are you gonna start your own brokerage?
- I don't think it's gonna be a brokerage.
I don't like the idea
of having a brokerage.
I don't want people to feel
like I own them in some way.
Right, like if anyone here
leaves their brokerage today,
any of your contracts that you have signed
that you haven't been paid on,
that brokerage is like, ha ha ha ha ha!
I did nothing for this and
I will take a massive cut,
and you can't go do what you want to do.
Some of you might have great agreements,
some of you might be able to cut and run,
I don't know what your situation is.
But most people, they're
tied into that brokerage
and that's a thing.
But does a brokerage
gives you leads every day?
Do they supply anything else other than
maybe some admin work you can
do with a TaskRabbit, right?
Like they say, there is an app for that.
It's an app, it's an app,
you should look it up.
Yeah, you can do things on your own now.
You don't need that brokerage
to pay for that person
to do that thing because
everything is automated.
Everything is automated.
- Oh wait--
- Everything's on YouTube,
everything's out there, you
don't need to do it anymore.
- Guys, wait 'til we get
to AI and machine learning.
TaskRabbit's gonna seem archaic.
It's just gonna automatically happen.
- And I think that instead of having
some powerhouse brokerages,
you're just gonna have a lot
of awesome brokers who
work for themselves,
or work in individual teams
and that's all that needs to happen.
And that's what I want to work towards.
You can tell anybody that I
said that, I just don't care.
- So right.
(audience applauding)
Well, good news, it's
being filmed at scale.
So this is not about telling anybody,
the data is there, it'll
be on the web in a second.
I think what's interesting
to me is it's how
AJ and I view the sports
representation business, right?
We started Vayner Sports because
when we look at the agents
that are taking commissions
for doing what has in the past
been important or had a value
but now has become completely different,
and so for me as you're talking,
I'm like, oh I see what he's saying.
It's the same as every business, you know.
What brokerages are gonna have to do
is they're gonna have to evolve.
For example, Vayner has
a much better chance
to start a brokerage because instead of--
- You want to do it?
- Maybe, I think, you know.
Because what I'm realizing is like,
oh I see, we can take
those fat commissions
and those healthy commissions,
but what we'll do is,
we'll create a model where it's not about
back-office or history,
we're gonna build out
people's personal brands at scale,
which is actually gonna
lead them into real revenue.
I'm gonna Vince McMahon you, right?
I'm gonna make you the Ultimate Warrior,
I'm gonna make you Hillbilly Jim,
that's where the money really is,
it's in actually doing something
that's tangible in reality.
So even though everybody
could be a badass broker,
a lot of people, what they
really need is brand equity
so that the funnel comes in.
And that's the only thing
the Vayner machine is,
is it's a communication,
you know, Deathstar.
- 100%.
- And so that's what it's gonna turn into.
- Yeah, I mean, look at,
in New York anyway, right,
we have--
- Got another business.
- We have designer gyms, right?
There's designer gyms all
the time, there's everywhere.
There's Barry's Bootcamp, there's Rumble,
there's Soul Cycle, there's
all these designer gyms.
I remember when you used to go to the gym
to lift weights or get on the treadmill.
Now, especially in New
York and other urban areas,
you go to work out because of a person.
You go to work out at, not at 9:00 a.m.
because that's when it's good for you.
You go at 10:00 a.m., you
work your schedule around,
because you're going with that trainer,
and that trainer's gonna
work out the best, right?
And we're addicted to it now,
I know in New York we are.
People are addicted to their trainers
and we wrap our lives around those people
and the gym space, right,
the equinoxes of the world,
have embraced that and
they're changing that model.
Same thing as brokerage.
You don't go to a Douglas Elliman, right,
because you're gonna
work with that chairman
or that brand, right, you're
going to that specific agent.
And so then what's the brand for?
What's it really do anymore?
And now I understand that right now,
still does a little bit, right,
because the our generation, my generation,
needs to get a little bit
older to phase things out.
And we will enact that change
and I will be at the front
of it, I swear to you.
- That sounds like a good admission.
I mean, look, what you know,
listening to the scattering of claps
when you talk about change,
everybody just listened to
that from their perspective.
So everybody just consumed
your four-minute rant on this issue
of squeezing out the middle, right?
This is all I think about,
and I think a lot of
what you're talking about
is a good subject to
spend the rest of time
because when I was listening to the claps,
and the energy of the room,
everybody just consumed
from their perspective.
If you're new, right, if
you're early in your career,
you're like, yeah, that's exactly right.
Like what the fuck, if
you're actually a brokerage,
you're like, fuck this dude,
this is how I make my dollars.
But this is super important
for everybody to understand.
I spent a lot of time with
companies that look like toys,
I spent, I loved Toys R Us growing up.
It was the kingdom, like
when my sister and I
got to go to Toys R Us,
that was like--
- Great, great, yeah.
- That was like everything, right?
And Toys R Us is based in New Jersey,
and so for the last four years,
I've taken four to six different meetings,
different restarts and resets
with the CEO or the CMO of Toys R Us
over the last six years
because it was emotionally,
you know, back to being able to do
anything you wanted every time,
it wasn't gonna be the biggest scope
or the best use of my time,
it was just fun for me
because it brought back great memories
and I wanted Toys R Us as a client.
And I would go in there and every time,
I would tell them, you
are in deep fucking shit.
There's basic data here.
Walmart is getting way too
much of the toy business,
that looks like you, right?
And Amazon's coming for your lunch.
And influencers are gonna
start selling this stuff
on YouTube Kids directly,
and where are you going?
And because they didn't
like what they were hearing,
they didn't hire me,
and a lot of times people don't hire me,
they'll just change, they
don't want to pay our premium,
they go for the second-rate
thing or the third-rate thing,
or try to do it internally
and do it themselves.
But Toys R Us did neither,
Toys R Us is out of business.
Toys R Us has no reason
for being out of business.
They could have made exclusive deals,
they could have sold directly.
All the Toys R Us in the country
could have turned into
entertainment systems and centers.
You don't want to spend
time with your kids,
you're gonna drop them off there
for fucking three hours and left,
they could have fucking dominated.
But because they were emotional
about how they got there,
so for everybody who was
just listening to Ryan
and didn't like what was
coming out of his mouth,
what I tell you to do is,
realize, take your money,
decide if you think he's right,
I'll give you the preview, he's right.
It's the Internet, my friends,
it's the fucking Internet.
It's not him or me, it's the Internet.
It eliminates everything
that is commodity.
So listen very carefully,
and adjust your model to be,
you know, it doesn't have
to, the term brokerage,
I'm a agency, Vaynermedia is an agency,
no different than fucking,
in your world the Elliman and
Remax or Weikart or whatever,
all that's in that world.
We have it, too, Ogilvy
and fucking, you know,
WPP and all this, we're the
same but we're different,
and I think for everybody who cares to be,
who's on the other side of
the conversation right now,
who's a brokerage, or building
one, or about to build one,
or cares about one, you can still do that.
What you provide has to change.
You could build a huge toy store today,
the biggest one in the world.
What you provide has to change.
A big box in a mall or a solid location
in a town where you walk in and
you buy it at a decent price
isn't good enough anymore.
The same way as in 1954
being in the downtown
and being a five-and-dime with toys
at a good healthy markup
became vulnerable to Toys R Us.
This is the thing that pisses me off.
I know nothing about
the brokerage industry,
I promise you, the brokerage
thing disrupted something else
that existed in real estate
30, 60, 90 years ago.
It's the same game.
Netflix is gonna get Punk'd one day too.
Because what happens is
people become complacent
and so, when you hear that rant,
I just highly recommend that
you're thoughtful about,
instead of saying fuck that,
putting your head in the sand
and thinking it's about a
successful guy's opinion,
this is about the fucking Internet
and it's gonna fucking break your face
unless you ride the wave
because too many of you
are looking at the wave coming at you
and you think you're somebody
because you've had some success,
this thing is gonna fucking kill you.
- Amen.
(audience applauding)
- And here's why I'm passionate about it.
It shouldn't kill you, all you have to do
is have the humility and
patience and work ethic
to grab that little
surfboard that's right here
and jump on it and ride this
thing to the fucking moon.
And my entire rant this morning was,
you're way ahead of 98%
of the people because
you wouldn't have spent the
money on the ticket to be here
if you weren't, you have to understand,
actions louder than words.
The fact that you know my content, right,
the fact that you even were in a funnel,
the fact that so many of you traveled,
how many people here flew
to be at this conference?
That's fucking ridiculous.
- Great.
- That's ridiculous, the
fact that you're there,
the fact that you're
there, you're so close.
Now the only thing that's holding you back
is the money and how you're making it now
and the complacency in that.
What do you want to leave everybody with?
What's a good general tone
for what you're seeing
from your day-to-day life
as an actual executor of this craft,
as a personal brand that's
using a different medium,
as you're getting the tone of
the last talk and this talk,
what's a good way to close out
these last couple of minutes?
What do you think is a
nuance or a thought starter
that's a little less theoretical?
Because I think you've established
a great overall strategy.
Is there anything that we
haven't touched on in my talk
or here right now that you
think may bring them value?
- Oh, I think that,
listen, I think that a lot of people
get nervous about the idea of control,
which you talk about a lot,
and if I'm gonna leave
this group with anything,
and I have one thing to
show everybody, right,
I want to make sure that we do that.
- This is why I never am like the host
or the person to ask questions.
I black out when I do talks.
Literally, there was only
one thing I had to do here,
and I fucked it up.
(audience laughing)
Thank you, Ryan for saving me.
- It's all right, don't worry.
- But obviously, you're
so good at what you do.
We're about to show you
something pretty rad.
We're approved still, right?
I know at some point it was kind of like,
can we do it can we not?
- We still can't do it, but
we're gonna do it anyway.
- That's really true, right?
- Yeah.
- So you're breaking
the rules a little bit?
- Yeah but, so control, fuck control.
Right, take control of your own life.
(audience laughing and applauding)
(upbeat orchestral music)